>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Pamela Jackson: Welcome.
OK. It's OK, great.
So I'm Pam Jackson.
I'm director for the
Center for the Book here
at the Library of Congress.
And we are part of the new National
and International Outreach
unit that's been created.
We welcome you here tonight.
I just want to mention a little
bit about the Library of Congress
and then I'll introduce our-- the
individuals that will be part--
the next individual who'll be
participating in our program.
And I feel I'm too
close to the microphone.
So a part of our vision
here at the Library is
that we are the chief steward of
the record of knowledge for America
and world, thus creating a
springboard to the future.
And the future I hope to see is one
of compassion and courage, industry
and innovation, remarkable
accomplishment, achievement,
one of peace and harmony.
Some of which is discussed in
the poems that we'll be hearing--
perhaps we'll be hearing
from tonight.
A part of the Library's
central mission is
to provide the American people with
rich diverse and enduring source
of knowledge that can be relied
upon to inform, inspire, and engage,
and to support intellectual
and creative endeavors.
And tonight, we have an opportunity
to enjoy a very special
creative endeavor
with the spotlight
on native writers.
This evening's event is sponsored
with the Library's Asian division
and the Poetry and
Literature Center.
And to find out more about both, we
do invite you to visit us on the web
at loc.gov/rr/asian for Asian
division and www.loc.gov/poetry.
Today's third annual event,
we've held in conjunction
with literary magazine
Manoa, a Pacific journal
of international writing
launched in 1989.
Manoa brings the literature of
Asia, the Pacific, and the Americas
to English-speaking readers.
To date, the journal has
published over 50 volumes
of about 10,000 pages and over 1200
writers, translators, reviewers,
and editors have participated
in those publications.
To find out more-- yup.
[ Applause ]
To find out more about that
journal, please visit their website
at manoajournal.hawaii.edu.
And I'd like to give a special
thanks to Manoa series editor,
Frank Stewart, for his tireless
efforts to bring world class writers
and writing to the
Library of Congress.
With Frank's help, we have
focused on the literature
of Okinawa and Singapore.
And tonight we turn to Korea.
We could not have a better
duo of literary exemplars
than Ko Un and Brother Anthony.
And on behalf of the Center
for the Book and the Poetry
and Literature Center, I
want to thank both of you
for traveling halfway around
the world to be here tonight.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
A quick word about our event,
for the opening hour or so,
Ko Un will read his poems
and Brother Anthony will
provide translations.
Afterwards, Frank Stewart will
lead a short moderated discussion.
Before we do begin, though, I'd like
to ask you to check that your phones
and devices, tablets
are turned to silent
so that they may not interfere
with the recording of the program.
And then I'll turn
to the next person
in our agenda Helena Zinkham will
explain how tonight's program
highlights the activities
of the Library's Collections
and Services division.
And a little bit about Helena.
She is the director for Collections
and Services and the chief of Prints
and Photographs Division
for the Library of Congress.
And where-- we have 15 million
images available for research
with more than 1 million
online at www.loc.gov/pictures.
And I have to mention this.
Helena fell in love with
pictures while she was working
at the Maryland Historical Society,
which was some number
of years before.
She's been at the Library
for quite awhile and is one
of our most premier experts
and personally she is a friend,
one of the most beautiful
people I know here
in the Library who's also an
extraordinary scholar and expert.
Please welcome her, Helena Zinkham.
[ Applause ]
>> Helena Zinkham: Hello everyone.
Can you hear well enough?
All right.
As the Library's director
for Collections and Services,
I'd like to offer you a quick
profile of our treasured holdings
and our world renowned
research guidance.
Founded in 1800, so that makes what?
216 years old and going strong.
We're the oldest federal cultural
institution in the United States.
And I think that's quite an
honor for a library, right.
It shows the value of our whole
country for knowledge and learning.
Not something that's obvious
everyday in our newspapers.
But tonight we're here to celebrate
the long, long traditions of culture
that the world has known
and created inspiration.
Despite our name, which of
course, includes the word Congress
and that is our primary
service point.
I would hope you come away from
this evening thinking of us
as America's Library, the National
Library of the United States.
We're the stewards for an
estimated 160 million items,
more than 450 languages.
Do you every thought about
that before, more than 450?
Well, of course, there are a lot of
printed books, around 24 million,
but also electronic
databases, manuscripts
and mass movies and music.
Pam mentioned the wonderful
photographs,
but also sound recordings.
How many miles of shelving
do you think that all takes?
I had to look it up.
But it turned out to be 848.
I think we could drive back and
forth to New York City many times
if we lined all the books
up along the highway.
Last year, we responded to almost
half a million reference requests
and we recorded almost 80
million visits to our website.
You heard Pam mentioned many URL
or web addresses, and that's,
of course, because many people are
not as fortunate as this evening
where you can come in
person to the Library
and hear the wonderful presentation.
So actually an awful a lot
of our services now online,
outreaching to the whole world.
You don't have to be
an American citizen.
You don't even have to
live in the United States.
We'll try to answer your questions.
The statistics might impress you
with our size and we are known
as the largest library in the world.
But what really matters, of
course, is content and quality.
We're fortunate enough to
have many unites filled
with subject matter experts.
And they provide reference
guidance and also insides
into these massive collections.
So don't let scale slow you down.
There are actually people
here, a human interface as well
as an electronic ready to answer
questions, or spark new ideas even
if you don't answer--
ask the question.
We'll check in.
Is there something you'd
like to know about?
A particular interest
this evening, of course,
are the international study areas,
which focus on specific
regions of the world.
We have four, European,
Hispanic, African, Middle East,
and the topic this
evening, Asian division.
The Asian division is a
prime example of the kind
of specialization that
emphasizes works written
in the vernacular languages.
For the case of Asian division that
includes China, of course, Japan,
India, Southeast Asia, and Korea.
Let's take a closer look
at the Korean collections.
And I hope if you don't
already have the handout,
it's out by the display.
Please be sure to pick
up a copy this evening.
The Korean collections
are known as the largest
but as importantly the most
comprehensive assemblage
of Korean language materials
outside of East Asia.
While the holdings do consist
primarily of works from 20th
and 21st centuries, a number
of important pre-19th century
publications are included.
And it really tickles
me that we express it
that way before the 1800s.
Well, let's try publications
from 1421 that were made
with movable type before Gutenberg
printed his bible in Europe,
so a fabulous collection.
As of today, a few more numbers,
303,000 books in the
Korean collection,
more than 7600 periodical
or magazine titles
and that includes everything
from the major magazines
to government reports in the
scholarly or academic journals.
In addition, our Korean team has
assembled more than 2500 reels
of microfilm so that you can have
access to 250 different newspapers.
Some of these numbers
still just blow me away.
One country Korea, 250 different
newspapers and all those opinions
and perspectives can be seen
here in the Library of Congress.
And the microfilm is going
back as far as the 1920s
with those newspapers and so
of course representing
the Korean Diaspora.
In terms of subject matter coverage,
the Korean collection compromise has
many topics, history, literature,
economy, technology,
religion, and the arts.
And we're also beginning to
get more digitized content out.
So through the world
digital library,
we began to put some Korean
books out on to the internet.
[Inaudible] tonight's presentation,
however, I'm pleased to point
out that the Library of Congress
has a significant collection
of publications by our
esteemed and it turns
out quite prolific speaker, Ko Un.
Would like to estimate?
247. I should have said
into the microphone.
But it's worth repeating
anyway, 247 works here
in the Library of Congress.
I think that's astonishing.
[ Applause ]
Specialist from the Asian division
have organized a sample display,
tip of the iceberg, but aren't
the covers of the books beautiful?
And I understood, you made
some of the paintings yourself.
Just lovely.
So we are honored this
evening to have Ko Un as well
as Brother Anthony with today.
They're the living embodiment
of that rich, diverse,
and enduring source of
knowledge that Pam spoke of
and that we seek to provide.
The poetry you will hear
tonight will surely inform,
inspire, and engage.
We can't say that too often.
Libraries are so often thought
of as factual, nonfiction,
the truth, the whole truth.
But the reality is,
we love literature.
We adore poetry.
Rob Casper is here this evening,
many others from the Poetry Center.
The creative imaginative
side of life is just
as important for our future.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: I
think-- Oh, take it away.
>> Brother Anthony: I
think I have to start.
I have to start by saying my
voice is in an unstable condition.
We'll see how it goes.
My name is Brother Anthony and
with Ko Un and then with Frank,
we are going to have
this reading with you.
And I don't want to spend much time.
There's lots to be done.
It's impossible to rarely introduce
a poet who has published something
like 155 books and who is now
in his 84th year in a few words.
When you go out, you will find
a handout, a printed text,
two pages summarizing the story
of his life and his poetic career,
which I prepared and also
a guide to publications
in English and homepages and so on.
So you can look at that at
leisure to learn about Ko Un.
At the start of this reading,
also, I have asked Frank Stewart,
the general editor of Manoa to
read the first section of poems.
The poems which were
published in the recent edition
of Manoa dedicated to Korean
poetry which I helped guest edit.
Copies are outside.
So seem [inaudible] the
English of these poems.
So before anything else,
see, Ko Un has lived
through the Japanese colonial
period, then the departure
of Japanese followed
by the Korean War.
Korean War followed by
the modernizing period,
which was dominated by regimes
of dictatorship involved
in the whole struggle
for democratization
and for basic human rights.
But he has always been from the
very start essentially a poet.
And so this evening we're going
to be listening to poetry.
And now to start the event, Ko
Un is going to say a few words.
And I will translate.
>> Ko Un: Good evening.
>> [Simultaneously] Good evening.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Brother Anthony: In Persia, poets
are venerated as gods or saints.
Hafez, [inaudible], and Rumi
are that kind of divine poet.
In the United States or Korea,
a poet is simply a poet.
[ Foreign Language ]
The American poet, Walt Whitman
embodies the American spirit
to such an extent that
he's regarded as one
of the founding fathers
in terms of spirit.
Hermann Hesse once praised
Whitman as the first American poet.
I think a great poet like him
is one of the grandfathers
of poetry irrespective
of nationality.
[ Foreign Language ]
"Leaves of Grass" is the
only collection Whitman left,
while I who belong to a much later
generation have written many poems,
probably my poet career
is in succession
to the ancient epic
tradition of Central Asia.
"Manimbo", a series of character
poems contains 4001 poems
in 30 volumes.
While the seven-volume epic
"Paektu san" might take seven
days to read completely.
But I've come here
across the Pacific working
on another lengthy epic
for the past 10 years.
But [inaudible] these
very long poems,
I also write very short
poems, many breathless poems,
only have one or two lines.
[ Foreign Language ]
In my poetry reading today,
in this great whole of books,
I would like to meet each one of
you through a few of my poems.
[ Foreign Language ]
Let me express my gratitude
in advance.
I want to thank especially Robert
Casper, the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center of the Library
of Congress, and also Frank Stewart,
the general editor of
Manoa for inviting me.
I'm also-- he says-- grateful to me,
Brother Anthony, for
all his efforts.
And above all to everyone
who's come here this evening
to share poetry together.
[ Foreign Language ]
I don't have so much curiosity
about the Capitol itself,
but I'm passionately curious
about all the provisions
of the planet contained
in the precious volumes
of this Library of Congress.
So I hope that my poems
through tonight will accompany
the souls of all those books.
[ Foreign Language ]
So now, we'll start reading.
And the first poems are going to
come from the volume untitled poems
and Ko Un will explain
what that's about.
[ Foreign Language ]
The collection untitled poems,
the most recent collection
that includes 607 poems in
some 1000 pages thick enough
to be used as a small pillow.
Three years ago, I lived in
Venice for four months invited
by a university there and most
of the poems emerge explosively
at some moments during our time.
I termed it a meteor
shower of poetry.
Ten of the poems were included
in the Manoa volume,
"The Colors of Dawn".
I'm going to read some of them now
and Frank Stewart will read the
English after each of poems.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Frank Stewart: Untitled poem 140.
How beautiful are the world's
10,000 years of answers and replies.
We've used them as
a stone, as a cave.
Reject them as lightning,
as moonlight,
suffer them as a stagnant puddle
as a naked body with scars shining.
The next day, shoot out
questions that cannot be answered,
as the sunspot, as a blind father.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
Untitled poem 148.
We need a song to sing
while walking along.
We need a song.
Not a song in some extravagant
stage or in a theater.
But three or four of us,
several of singing together,
comforting each other, consoling
each other, on a weary night road.
We need a song not
the ideological kind.
Not the military march kind.
But a sad song to sing as we
walk along barefoot at night,
a little remainder of an old fashion
custom from our African ancestors.
We need a song for the road.
We need a song we sing walking
together, a song like lamenting,
like congratulating, like
praying most awfully.
A song of my ancestors and a song of
my own, an incantation transmitted
over a million years, song that
is a river and also a fountain.
We need a song which
those who are sleeping
in some distant village
wake up with and listen
to with closed eyes while
waiting for a new sleep to come.
We need a song, a walking
song that insects, stars,
and dead souls to cherish.
We need a song, a song whose weight
neither low nor high reaches the
light of dawn at day break.
On that site of the song,
people sing standing.
On this side of the song people sing
in a bar convivially vigorously.
I will live as a walking song.
I will walk along as that
song with nothing more I want
for the remaining days if
there are days remaining.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
Untitled poem 179.
Stream in alps, who would see you
on their way, stay all on your own,
a stream with a color
of spoiled [inaudible],
then a river like a
slate gray complexion
of an unfamiliar youthful in-law.
Then go to the sea.
The world is simply busy
having no moment to feel sorry.
When you reach the sea,
even if you have no color
of your own, the clouds
will dye you.
The sky will dye you.
The majestic power of the
setting sun will turn you
into a sea of fire.
There, enjoy living several
years letting everything go.
[ Foreign Language ]
Untitled poem 193.
These are my beliefs.
I believe in morning dew.
I believe in the rain that
will come a few days later.
I believe in the wind.
I believe in the smell
of shit born on the wind.
I believe gangsters' nights.
I believe not in truth but in
the fact that the truth changes.
Now with skepticism I believe
that there's nothing
at all to believe in.
My belief is something else again.
[ Foreign Language ]
Untitled poem 201.
A mouse listens to
a Scops owl's cry.
By day a dog with nothing else
to do listens to calf lowing.
I listen to ogres talking
from far away, far away,
far away from that unbounded place
on the western shore
of Ching Hai Lake.
Meaning having vanished,
only the sounds remain.
I listen to ethnic Koreans,
Chinese, I listen to English,
I listen to British English,
and Californian English,
respectively in a state
where meaning is nullified only
the sacredness of sound remains.
Meaningless interpretations, truth
that are this planet's catastrophes.
You work hard for thousands
of years.
Now be off with you.
Farewell. I listen to your words as
the call of the goose by night only
as the fossils of sounds.
As a snail or butterfly
listens to my words.
Meaningless consonants and vowels,
reality in the origin, sounds.
[ Foreign Language ]
Untitled poem 215.
Time coming is that slow.
Time going is this fast.
Graves and the memorial
stones in front
of graves murmur once
exposed to rain.
The next day when sunshine comes,
all that was wet dries
out, shuts up.
Even the sky is blue for no reason.
Time going vanishes.
Time coming has not yet come.
Living things on such a day
have nowhere to go and to come.
After all, time does
not belong to humans.
[ Foreign Language ]
Number 485.
The sun is rising.
Today, too, I will fight.
Today, too, I will lose the fight.
>> Brother Anthony: Let's see.
End of the first section,
the untitled poems.
And now Ko Un and I
will read 10 short songs
from a collection called
"Poetry Left Behind".
[ Foreign Language ]
At the edge of a reed field,
mallard ducks about to leave are
pluming their feathers awhile.
[ Foreign Language ]
A cold wind stirs the yellow
feathers of baby chicks,
chicks' legs stay thin
for a long time.
[ Foreign Language ]
A sound thump was heard
like the sound
of a huge rock being laid flat.
Was that a sound the darkening
mountain made by itself?
After that the owl's
eyes became bigger.
[ Foreign Language ]
In a stable where to the bitter end
a sick horse refused to kneel down,
a faint light of dawn is spreading.
It was a long night, a long night.
[ Foreign Language ]
Grandfather spoke brokenly.
You have a long way to go.
Don't hurry.
Go plodding along like an
ox and rest once and awhile.
[ Foreign Language ]
Do I have the love of one person
that can wash away the
hatred of several people?
I have been opening an
umbrella, but I close it again
and just welcomed the rain.
[ Foreign Language ]
I asked a child, "Do you want
to be a baker or a thief?"
And the child asked, "Why, is there
nothing but that in this world?"
Indeed so.
There is only Caspian Sea and
the Black Sea in this world.
[ Foreign Language ]
Let go of the things you have
spent 30 years shouting for.
Among them justice,
let it go forever.
[ Foreign Language ]
10 years, 30 years, or 50 years, if
such time spans were not transient
and such life spans were not
transient humans would have become
so much more barbarous.
Oh, long live sublime transience.
[ Foreign Language ]
Today maybe a trivial day, it's
the day someone is being born,
the day someone is leaving,
the day someone is waiting,
today too may the glow of
the setting sun be glorious.
[ Foreign Language ]
These are poems from the
collection "First Person Sorrowful",
which you'll found outside, poems
written after the year 2000.
"Poetry Left Behind", if it's
possible, if it's really possible,
why should there not be times
when we start over again
from our mother's womb
as if newborn.
Life always has to listen alone
to the sound of the next wave.
Still we should not turn back
from the road once taken.
Tatters of the years
while I wondered
about are flapping here
and there like laundry.
When I was poor, even
tears were lacking.
Some nights I warmed my cold
back of the dwindling bonfire,
then turning tearlessly
warm my breast.
Some other nights I simply
froze and shudder trembling.
Whenever countless
tomorrows become today,
I was often a stranger
in a back seat.
At dusk the mountains were
so deep that the road I have
to take seemed longer than
that which I had taken.
The wind blew, blew.
Was that a spirit howling
once or poetry?
Sorrow is never something
we sell or buy.
So be sorrowful as a
lamp standing far beyond.
There should be nothing
that I have left.
But feeling there was something
I left behind as fog is lifting.
I rose quickly from the spot
where I had been staying likely
on the west coast near the
outermost tip of the Pan Peninsula.
Was that a soul howling at some
period of my life or poetry?
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
Song of white.
One life dreams of another life.
Late spring white pair blossoms
their hearts throbbing await
the moon.
One life resembles another life.
In the summer night the field of
buckwheat flowers awaits the moon.
One life in humans another life.
It's winter, the snow that fell
heavily yesterday awaits the moon
with all its heart.
I throw a stone, buried in the snow.
It begins another life.
Finally, the moon rises.
[ Foreign Language ]
Mother. A woman walking
alone murmurs
as though she has a companion.
A woman reading a novel
weeps with weeping
of a woman abandoned in the novel.
Isn't such a woman at times
also someone's mother?
How can the lady Maya
of Ancient India alone?
Was Virgin Mary alone be a mother?
And a woman who has no child, yet,
can search through the darkness
after sunset, isn't
she also a mother?
[ Foreign Language ]
The United Nations some
years back reckoned
that it should promote
happiness seeing
that humanity was leaving further
and further away from happiness.
And so they established happiness
day and they commissioned
of the world's poets
including myself to write poems
on the topic of happiness.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Laughter ]
The indistinct happiness.
Who would know flocks of
migrant birds fly across the sky
with no despair, by day, by
night, from Siberia to Oceania?
Who would know the revolving
planets, westerly winds blow past
with no rest from the
western part of Eurasia
to East Asia beyond East Asia
to the North Pacific below
the illusion islands?
Who would know shoals
of old salmons swim
across the water braving
the ocean tides
and currents devoting their lives
to the far away home
they left years before?
Who would know the lives of
bent old men and old women past
through blind times as they
work on scraps of paddy field
in the Korean peninsula
from sunrise to sunset?
Who would know?
Happiness does not exist elsewhere
apart from wearisome life and death.
The moment of happiness
cannot be known.
Who would know?
Be thus indistinct happiness.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
The whisper.
Rain falls, I sit at my desk.
The desk speaks softly.
Once I was a flower,
was leaf, was a stalk.
I was a long root beneath
the ground stretching
as far as young dessert oasis.
A scrap of iron on the desk speaks.
I was the uvula of a steeliness
howling alone on moonlight nights.
The rain stops.
I go outside.
Grass thoroughly soaked
speaks to me.
Once I was your joy and sorrow.
I was your history and songs.
Now I speak to desk,
to iron, to earth.
Once I was you, was you, was you.
Now I am you.
I am you.
[ Foreign Language ]
In 2013, I was invited to the first
International Poetry Festival we
held in Cape Town in South Africa.
I set out on that long
journey looking forward
to seeing the Southern
Cross in the sky.
And one of the themes
of the festival was the
poets' own biography.
And so I wrote this poem.
[ Foreign Language ]
Biography.
I was born as butterfly
with a life which might
or might not have existed.
But a small eyes open to the light
in the darkness very
thin wings emerged.
Knowing nothing like
the sea like storms
that one butterfly always
delighted on the leaves
of an overthrown nation
it flew from here, there.
It was as if somebody knew from
the start how absurd immortality is
in the fields where
sunset alone was great.
Day was a colonized land.
Night was my fatherland.
In those nights, my forbidden
mother tongue murmured unnoticed
by any inside my sleeping body.
Liberation came, my
mother tongue was splendid.
War came, among the ruins
between the corpses in the ruins,
my blood stained mother
tongue survived.
I sang in that mother tongue.
My song was a mourning.
My song was someone's resurrection.
And my song was a song of
extinction not immortality.
I stood before dictatorship
and guns.
My incantation was
several times imprisoned.
Contradiction gave birth to
narratives of contradiction
and lyrics rejecting contradiction.
Still, that baby butterfly
of days long ago is dreaming
at one place on earth.
It was [inaudible]
some other places.
Life goes wondering on
inwardly, unfinished.
One dream remains.
May the fossilized
butterfly underground
in some distant future
be a fossilized song?
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
In Lhasa, Tibet I was at an
altitude of some 400,000 meters,
the Zangbo River sped
by fiercely a hat thrown
in would vanish in a flash.
Turning around I slowed my breathing
by half following the octagonal path
through Lhasa's old city I turned
like a slow spinning wheel.
Such a crowd of beggars
gathered and so jubilant,
among them was one old beggar, all
wrinkles and just two yellow teeth.
He laughed like a fool
and said only one thing.
Not got a few pennies.
Nothing like that.
My goodness.
Not that kind of the oh begging.
But "You're the highest,"
just that one phrase.
In a word, I was astounded,
really astounded.
My poor wondering souls brought to
a full stop, awakened in amazement.
Yesterday, today, or
tomorrow, never was there was
or will there be such
a way of begging.
No such begging would be
plausible anywhere else anytime.
And the place I've come to and the
places I'll go back to in the world
of thunder and lightning
400,000 meters below,
who would ever pay tribute to me
with empty hands saying
"You're the highest."
Humbled by such extravagant respect,
how could I respond
with a few pennies?
So I fumbled to give him a bank
note with a portrait of Mao
on it and made my escape.
On reflection like him I am
doubtless most wretched of beggars.
Days past and yesterday too in order
to lay my hands on a single line
of poetry and also on that space
between the lines I never stop
sucking for milk that would not come
like a hungry baby thrusting its
lips against every breast insight.
It's been 50 years since I first
beg anxiously for one word,
the truest word between words
from some valley in this world,
from some slope in the world
beyond or from some edge
of the infinite fathomless universe.
Spirit of one word,
"You're the highest."
There I now hope to rise
to that peak of begging.
Only my happiness is, I'm not thief.
My unhappiness that I'm
forever a beggar, that's all.
You are the highest.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
So in 2005, Korea was the guest
of honor Frankfort Book Fair.
And I was asked to make a keynote
speech of the [inaudible] Ceremony.
And I was also asked by one of the
major daily newspapers in Germany
to write a poem for them.
And it was presented right in the
center of the first page in German
and in Korean in my own handwriting.
And that's the poem I'll read now.
[ Foreign Language ]
First person sorrowful.
I am sad. Enlightenment soon
becomes a contradiction.
After the revolution early last
century the Soviet poets decided
they would only say "We."
They decided they would
only call themselves "We."
They were enchanted.
Their decision held even when they
could not go out into the streets,
even when they lingered
indoors due to heavy blizzards.
They took oaths saying
"We", by themselves.
"I" had disappeared somewhere
deep in the looking-glass.
Mayakovsky, too, one
bright sunny day,
dashed out shouting
and shouting "We."
He was a poet of the street.
"I" was not allowed anywhere.
"I" was wicked.
"We We" that alone
had incantatory power.
Little by little, a
low-pressure front settled in.
Summer flowers kept being trampled.
Revolution devoured revolution.
The air went out of
every child's ball.
And likewise the tall, round
atmosphere of "We" slowly went flat.
Someone boldly wrote "I
am in love," but still
as long the custom it
read as "We are in love."
Winter snows had not all melted.
Spring is always uncertain.
Late last century the
Soviet Union disappeared.
Countries dropped out of the
Warsaw Pact one after another.
And since then poets
have nothing but "I."
Starting with "I" they
end the day with "I."
There is nothing except "I."
God, too, is another name for "I."
Today, I bury the ghosts
of "We" and "I"
in the endless waves
of the Pacific Rim.
"Who" will be born.
"Who" will be born
neither "We" nor "I."
Each wave is one wave's
grave, another wave's womb.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
So "Arirang".
This poem is called "Arirang".
And "Arirang" is a Korean song.
It's a national song.
In Korea it's more widely loved
and probably more often sang
than the official national anthem.
And after Koreans had lost their
nation and everything with it
and many then left for a life
elsewhere, the only thing they took
with them were the dates of their
ancestor's death anniversaries
and this song.
So I'm going to read
it first in English
and Ko Un will read it in Korea.
"Arirang".
One day in 1937, Koreans living
in far eastern Siberia were
abruptly loaded onto freight trains
on the trans-Siberian railway.
Carried for 10 days of [inaudible]
along the shore Lake Baikal
and beyond.
5000 of them, as people
died one by one.
Their bodies were thrown
out along the way.
Where on earth are they now?
Reaching the barren land of Alma
Ata [phonetic], they were unloaded.
You [foreign language] live here.
Then the empty trains left.
The Tien Shan mountain range far
to the south was white with snow.
Everywhere before and behind
was all bare weedy land.
And here they began to construct
dugouts to place cooking pots,
to live in the midst of death.
And 60 such harsh years past,
the second generation was born,
third their children took
names like Natalia Kim,
Ilich Pak [assumed spellng].
One of them called
Anatole Kang, 11 years old,
was good at playing the balalaika.
One day, he was given the
musical score of "Arirang".
He scanned it once and
began to play and sing.
And how amazing.
As the child sang, he found he'd
never felt such deep sorrow.
Tears rose in his eyes, never before
that he felt such deep sorrow.
It was the first time
he'd ever sung "Arirang"
yet all his ancestors
grief was in it.
From which the child's tears
could never be far removed.
Was that blood or a song or what?
"Arirang".
"Ariryo".
[ Applause ]
>> Ko Un: "Arirang".
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Applause ]
[ Singing ]
>> Ko Un: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Brother Anthony: Now,
briefly, Frank is going to ask one
or two questions and I will try
to interpret and Ko Un will answer
and I will try to interpret
>> Frank Stewart: Thank you.
Thank you.
I think all of us would wonder
how many Ko Uns are there.
There seemed to be too
many to be in one person.
Can he please talk about how he
manages to be so many people?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Brother Anthony: I'm not
the on-- I'm not the only one.
Everybody-- There's nobody in fact.
It's just one person.
[ Foreign Language ]
There's I, I, alone.
There's no need for this name Ko Un.
[ Foreign Language ]
Because I'm just the one.
Of course, I'm my daughter's father.
[ Foreign Language ]
And my wife's husband.
My friends' friend.
[ Foreign Language ]
You know, I have many friends.
And friend of Anthony, me.
[ Foreign Language ]
And friend of Frank.
I'm very complex.
[ Foreign Language ]
That's one way of saying.
My writing is perhaps, yes,
not just one person's writing.
[ Foreign Language ]
Practically speaking.
I have three desks in my study.
[ Foreign Language ]
Poetry?
And long extended epics.
[ Foreign Language ]
And you're pros.
I write in different places.
[ Foreign Language ]
And sometimes there
are additional desks.
[ Foreign Language ]
A very famous carpenter in
Korea made desks for me.
[ Foreign Language ]
Very, very long desk.
And then all these different chairs
so I can sit different places.
[ Foreign Language ]
So my writing is not single.
It's plural.
It's multple.
[ Foreign Language ]
And certainly I'm not alone one.
In the space?
[ Foreign Language ]
Yeah.
I'm composed of dust from the
cosmos, from the whole cosmic dust.
[ Foreign Language ]
From all these different
stars and planets
and from all these different
countries and peoples and cultures,
everything all together make me up.
[ Foreign Language ]
But it's true I am a Korean poet.
I'm very complex.
[ Foreign Language ]
It's impossible.
Nobody can be single and simple.
[ Foreign Language ]
Not one doesn't really
exist in this world.
[ Foreign Language ]
So this plurality we should
acclaim and be grateful for.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.